welcome to Miami and it is opening night
but the Jonas Brothers World Tour
happiness begins right yes and only et
is gonna take you backstage you guys
ready we're ready ready it has been six
years since you guys have been together
going out on tour how does it feel when
you look there and you see that you're
back together again it's an incredible
feeling and you know this tour in a lot
of ways was kind of the perfect storm
everything between sucker and cool the
other songs in the record coming out I
think all of it was kind of pointing
towards this moment to be back on stage
together was about saying okay are we
good as family first making that the
priority and you know after about a year
and a half and doing some real work on
that having those tough conversations we
got to a point where we actually said
okay we can do this again it's gonna be
a crazy night guess who else agrees the
20,000 screaming fans who collectively
lost their mind for this reunion six
years in the making
and let's just talk about the VIP
section for a moment all three of their
wives attended the concert kickoff
including Joe's newlywed sophie Turner
and Nick's bride of eight months
Priyanka Chopra they're all here tonight
and our parents aren't sound it's like
an it is an army yeah it's gonna be a
party are we done with wedding
celebrations and all that stuff we had
them there we go is it over
we got Frankie Jonas so there's one left
a single he's single currently don't
want to show you guys your first ET
interview oh boy and you guys talking
about the wildest things your fans have
done a fan actually adopted the hip up
so there's a hippo out there named Jonas
Brothers it's a pretty cool feeling it's
a pretty cool feeling we have got so
many stars in our name at hair I have
like 100 stars pretty hundred and one as
a hundred stars what is different this
time - back then there's quite a bit I'd
say our hair is a little shorter ya know
that the pants are a little bit looser I
don't know they're still pretty skinny
their skinny jeans still how cool is it
that your fans have grown up with you
now like a lot of people can't make that
transition
the thing that was most surprising to us
one of the first shows we did back was
our fans were tipsy at the show which
was played our music to people drinking
necessarily and now that's sort of the
objective at the show and we're meeting
a lot of people that say that their kids
are named after us which is interesting
by the way I saw Justin Bieber rocking
the Jonas Brothers shirt yes it was very
cool I mean we love our fans Nora let me
tell you their fans love them back their
happiness begins tour is presented by
the American Airlines MasterCard only et
can take you behind the scenes there's a
lot of surprises in store for the show I
mean our entrance alone we come from all
the way up top there how did you choose
the music and was there any like push
and shove about wait we're leaving that
out
yeah there's 230 songs we've literally
230 songs in our catalogue and then you
have Nick's solo stuff
[Music]
Dean sees stuff trying to chop down this
setlist so we can at least hit under
three hours good stuff we were able to
do it and we're pretty proud kevin
revealed another huge secret about how
they remember all those lyrics
teleprompter like in the floor hidden if
we're gonna be doing songs that i
haven't played since i was 13 14 years
old it's good to have that in the back
pocket now you know all the secrets so
try to keep it I'm gonna keep it all you
don't put it on TV if you don't mind oh
what's going it's ly opening up for the
joke grows on the road hitmaker bebe
Rexha I'm actually just wanting to be
friends with the why
BB's all about girl power and body image
proud to be a size six to eight for the
Grammys when a lot of the top designers
and I want to dress me because I didn't
fit in to their size zeros like their
sample sizes that hurt me
I think inclusivity is really important
yeah I think that you have to like
include all women not even women men as
well also opening up for the Joe Broz
Jordan McGraw drama he's the 32 year old
youngest son of dr. Phil who texted him
with advice before his big opening night
they said look around and take it in and
enjoy it and then go kill it big brother
Jay surprised him by flying in Jordan's
been buds with the Jonas Brothers a
while and Joe even appeared in Jordan
this video flexible they called me and
asked me to go on tour like it was a
question and that was like of course
absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]